all right so the good news is we got our
set here we got a really nice green
screen room we're gonna be putting
furniture and stuff in here we're gonna
have a real nice bag for him for it he's
not gonna be in but I am and that's
what's gonna make it so great I'm just
gonna be lovely but the downside is I
don't know if you can hear but echo let
go a little bit of an echo so we have
Mike coming in that we're gonna have in
here you know with the furniture and
stuff like that but setback setback so
for this week again we are just gonna do
sort of the basic in front of the couch
kind of thing but just letting you know
we do have it it is put up and we got my
own Avicii furniture out there but it is
here and we are gonna have that set up
up until then ah so anyway until that's
ready and I am Iron Man's brother Rob
iron Rob and this is sibling rivalry
I'm not afraid of you no politics here
just good old-fashioned revenge Tony
Stark is back as Iron Man in the third
installment of the most likely not
trilogy I'm sure they're gonna make more
of ace the increasingly inaccurately
named trilogy that's going to happen and
this time he's going up against the
Mandarin played by Ben Kingsley he's the
head of a terrorist organization called
the ten rings and he pisses them off so
much that not only do they try and take
out his bodyguard but they also tried to
take out his girlfriend and his home and
Tony Stark is out for all-out war
um the surface this pretty much seems
like a very straightforward comic book
film and on the surface that's
essentially all it is which if you're
looking for a straightforward comic book
film it's great however if you're
looking for something that's a little
bit more meaty it's a little bit more
development there's two major problems
with it one is Tony Stark
this bastard never learns from his
mistakes and it's finally getting to a
point where it's getting a little
annoying I mean this is a guy who
literally out of emotional anger goes on
TV announces his home address to the
world calling out the terrorists and has
no back-up plan and guess what happens
they come and blow his house up guess
who's at home - by the way pepper yes
yes his girlfriend they see - they tend
to show the scene where she was watching
the television at the time going but
this you can imagine this has got to be
the dumbest move in superhero history
giving out your home address thingy or
something he has a plan and he has no
plan you could have also let Vicky Vale
into the Batcave but you know okay if
you want to okay this certainly I think
this is worse good this is death this
isn't done by his Butler this isn't done
by his AI or any think this is done by
Tony Stark and that even though that's
probably the biggest there's a couple
mistakes that he makes like this these
emotionally fueled mistakes from a
supposedly brilliant man and at first I
think they're kind of acceptable cuz
he's going through a story arc but after
a while you really want to punch this
guy because he's putting people in
danger and then the other problem I'll
also name is that there's a lot twists
and turns in
this movie which is usually good uh and
this does throw you for a lot of
surprises but halfway there's a major
twist in it of course we won't give it
away I think a lot of people are gonna
be pissed off
you obviously have not been on the
Internet in the past couple days are
people pissed off oh yeah okay okay a
little bit there you go the film builds
up that this is gonna be a massive movie
this is the you know all-out war revenge
but the way up boy it's like building up
a really really good awesome football
game and then halfway through they give
you a baseball game now the baseball
game is the beeth what do you got
against baseball no no the baseball game
is decent on American best the baseball
game is decent but you're kind of
wishing you were gonna get that football
game they were really building up so in
my opinion even though it's promising a
football game you don't get it but the
baseball game is a decent baseball game
if that makes any sense that's the best
way I can point so I do recommend it
just as a fun little comic book movie
and you know good action a lot of funny
one-liners but if you're looking for
something deep if you're looking for
evolution of the character or a really
clever large epic story you're probably
not gonna get it hear your thoughts
okay goodnight folks I'm out the funny
thing about this week there was all this
talk in the movie about mechanics and
Tony Stark goes through this phase where
he's just like I'm a mechanic I am this
and since they're all about the
mechanics I the only way I can describe
this movie is is perfectly serviceable
it's like taking your it's like taking
your car in which is on its last leg and
getting all of these things fixed and
getting your car back and being like
yeah you know what it's driving all
right there's still a rattle here there
and they could have done a better job
but when it's all said and done I can
freaking drive so if that's works yeah I
wouldn't be awesome you got that really
awesome car that the mechanic was
building on this is not a case we're
gonna drive your car in and get a brand
new Ferrari out of it the funny thing is
I liked it fine coming out of the cinema
about 20 minutes afterwards I started to
think about it and that's when it
started to fall apart so if you go in
and just turn your brain off and don't
think you'll be like hey this is a lot
of fun
a good time there was some funny lines
you know like Tony Stark in the movie he
turns his brain off doesn't think he
seems to have fun yeah if that helps you
yes it's not that there's a twist
the initial twist is actually really
good and once you get through just like
oh that's awesome that's cool well now
what are they gonna do though and then
afterwards is like oh really that was it
like you know that's all I can say
without really giving it away but it's
like it's a great idea that they just
don't execute well it's like oh that's
an awesome idea now let's see what the
payoff is for that awesome idea nothing
like nothing really it is clever
yeah I'd even argue there's some like
there's some good social commentary in
there I would say you know even about
the media have the need for villains
though yeah without going too much into
it I mean there is it is clever but it
doesn't give you the payoff that it's
really building up I mean and again it's
not just the trailers if it was just the
trailers I say false advertising but the
first half I think we can say does build
up this is gonna be a huge epic revenge
flick the climax is actually really good
it's probably the best shot thing in the
film but the other problem is they have
rose films were shot really beautifully
I mean every single frame was composed
well it looked like a comic book come to
life you know you had your characters in
the foreground in just the right way you
had the action said just the right way
this is more like a bad Chris Nolan
Batman sort of vibe where Chris Nolan
would have big moments the truck
flipping over in Dark Knight but so many
action scenes it's like I'm just gonna
point the camera at a couple of people's
very basic do stuff you know and yeah
and even just your standard shots are
just so not composed there's there's
nothing visually interesting going on
whereas the first two Iron Man's as much
as I didn't like Iron Man to Lisa it was
interesting to look at there's not
really much to chew on in this film when
it comes to just like that comic book
movie feel of like bright colors and
great action sequences and stuff but do
you also see what I'm talking about with
the with the main character now you have
read the Iron Man comics I haven't but
do you see what I'm talking about with
is there anything else to do with this
guy because it seems like the big
was in the first movie and then all the
other movies he's saying no no I'm
smarter than I look and he clearly isn't
because he has all these brilliant ideas
but he makes these dumb emotional
choices that aren't about this bed right
away not that it's not that there's
nowhere to go with the character it's
that the screenwriter didn't know what
he was doing I mean it's not a panic
attack which that goes nowhere there's
nothing you're right that goes nowhere
he's like I'm gonna have panic attacks
cuz in the Avengers happen never sends
in the Avengers when the aliens are
coming through and ever since that oh no
no girlfriend remember he's afraid he
might lose the girlfriend so that's why
he sends up a robotic double to say hi
and not even greet her at the door and
then gives away his home address or her
to get blue yeah it seemed that like
three or four times has to get herself
out that's very sloppy script with good
ideas not executed well the only really
good thing is the middle portion of the
movie is actually the best which is a
rarity he meets up with this kid and
it's just one of the most brilliantly
like written sequences I've seen in a
comic-book movie in a long time because
this one scene so encapsulate s'what
comic books do for kids like if I were
10 years old I would be like Tony
Stark's in my garage oh oh like and the
relationship he has with that kid which
is could have been so cheesy and it
always comes it comes really close they
they joke yeah if this is it is not an
Anakin Skywalker scene and this is not
Jake Lloyd the child actor they found is
pitch perfect with lines there most kids
wouldn't be able to deliver naturally
and this kid pulls it off and their
relationship which is very cynical still
but really very touching that part of
the movie was the best part of the movie
and that's where he realizes you know
he's like I'm a mechanic which I thought
was a nice solution for the panic
attacks which were under explored but
he's like maybe I should just work just
work through it you know and then whole
such in the movie was great and the
payoff at the end for that was great I
mean it's worth the price of admission
alone for me for that bit in the middle
of the movie I didn't feel he learned a
damn thing I felt like oh well I I don't
have as many of my toys but we've
clearly proven I can keep making them
I'm just gonna keep making the toys I
feel he did and I feel the ending stated
that and I feel that's where they were
going with it and I'll believe it just
enough
because the script is telling me to but
because there's going to be an Avengers
sequel and most likely an Iron Man for
the rumors already out I'm just like ok
so you say that he learned something but
the next films are just gonna probably
completely dump on that so it maybe it's
the fact that it's like you know you
can't have this guy learn too much
because we we like him as a cynic we
like him as the person who says the
one-liners so we don't want to see him
learn too much he has to be able to solo
note everybody likes Han Solo from
Empire the best who says Johan I really
like the one from Return of the Jedi
where he was in carbonite for the first
third of the movie and then he felt up
by Ewoks and then basically kind of gets
Leia and is all domesticated he's doing
that movie basically got the Rebel
Alliance in a lot of trouble because he
keeps stepping on it's me you know it
you know fly casual Chewie it yeah I
mean so the you're right he can't learn
too much because you don't want to
destroy what is the essence of the
character to some degree he's always
gonna have to be immature but it's like
bothers me is they're trying to say he
learned something while also saying yeah
but we're just gonna keep this series
going forever so probably whatever he
learned in this movies not gonna carry
over into the next one I felt like I was
watching Bruce Wayne from The Dark
Knight movies as everyone progresses he
gets more and more brilliant tech wise
but dumber and dumber as a human being
well he's a really stupid yeah I don't
see the evolution in the choices he's
made here's a guy who always has a
back-up plan yet he always puts himself
in position where anyone would have a
back-up plan going into it and he never
does but it's not the character it's the
writer
yes but the writer creates the character
I I know but I'm saying it's you said is
this character just done are we and I'm
like no if you read the comics there's
plenty of places you could go with it
it's just the writer didn't know what to
do it is fun it's a fun movie and I
remembered it I couldn't tell you what
the hell happened in Iron Man 2 if
somebody put a gun to my head right now
and said tell me what happened in Iran
to I'm gonna blow your brains out I
really
there was no that's it Ellison nothing
else I'd see ones I did not think it was
the worst Iron Man I thought it was
lightyears ahead of Iron Man - it was
not as good as Iron Man one and yeah it
was it was dumb fun you know it was dumb
fun in the moment if you're looking for
the greatest comic book movie ever made
but for firfer dumb funds cool effects
great gizmos some good one-liners and as
you said serviceable characters it's
yeah it's decent it's funny though we
just go some action you know and enjoy
so that's about it our Bob and his
brother Rob we'll see you next time